who doesn't love the zombies you know
they're always chasing you there's
always more of them and they keep you
alert and but also who doesn't love a
good alien we all want to meet the
aliens so when I think of these these
forces that rise up in the storytelling
of science fiction I think it all
started with Frankenstein Mary Shelley's
Frankenstein I'm not sure what might
come next we still ride in that zombie
thing that's been going for decades
zombies then I don't see them fading
away anytime soon vampires
I don't know I was never scared of
vampires I think I can kick some vampire
but it's like he's gonna get that close
when you bite my neck just get out of
here
so I don't
I was never distracted by vampires
zombies are a little scarier plus
zombies are are the beginning of the end
of the world
whereas vampires they're just trying to
they're just trying to live but I have
no idea I'm not a good future predictor
I mean I think I'm an acute observer of
how the past has influenced the present
but how the present might influence the
future I don't know
you